one of the things that's becoming more
and more clear as we learn about Michael
Cohen's sentencing memo from Robert
Muller
and as we see Donald Trump's erratic
reactions and we see conservative
pundits like Jennifer Rubin say they
predict that Donald Trump's gonna resign
and try to get a pardon from Mike Pence
in the midst of all this this is a sort
of constant that we see which is that
Donald Trump jr. appears to be in really
big trouble why do I say that well
because every new piece of evidence
every new piece of testimony every new
document that we see related to the
Trump Russia indictment in two
indictments look like they're saying
that Don jr. lied and therefore should
be expecting an indictment and
specifically it seems that Donald Trump
jr. lied to Congress about the Trump
family's business in Russia this is not
like some esoteric idea there are
members of Congress who are plainly
saying Donald Trump jr. lied to us
here's just one example this is
Democratic congresswoman Jackie Speier
check it out
do you think Donald Trump jr. lied to
your committee I believe he did about I
don't really want to go into it at this
point but I think there's at least two
occasions when he lied to the committee
so in addition to these lies there's
more and more legal scrutiny over Donald
Trump Jr's involvement in that Trump
Tower meeting that we've talked about so
much which once again seems to have been
much more significant than initially
reported remember that Trump jr. first
said there was no meeting then he said
okay there was a meeting but it was
about adoptions of Russian children then
his emails were released which confirmed
that he had foreknowledge that the
meeting was taking place with Russians
and it was specifically about dirt on
Hillary Clinton Don jr. seems to know
that he's in trouble I think it was last
week or the week before that I reported
to you that he's been telling friends
that he thinks Moeller is going to
indict him and the latest news is that
Donald Trump jr. is hiding out in Canada
to avoid the media if and when this
possible indictment happens which
apparently could be very very soon
that last this is sort of like the last
this story and the prediction is that
the bomb is close to dropping and Don Jr
wants to be out of the US when it
happens Gabriel Sherman who has done
some really good reporting on this wrote
in Vanity Fair that the Trump family
overall is expecting things to implode
this week or next week and that Don jr.
specifically is saying I'm out of here
for now we've been talking about this
for a while Pat and I think in one of
our polls wasn't Don jr. the winner of
the most likely insider to next be
indicted yeah so there was Don jr. there
was Roger stone there was maybe Jared
Kushner but Don Jr certainly won out and
I would have to agree with that
assessment listen maybe Don jr. could
seek asylum in Canada claiming he's the
victim of political prosecution of
course but by his dad's own Justice
Department or something
obviously I'm kidding Canada wouldn't
accept that as an asylum claim by the
way there's also an extradition treaty
between the United States and Canada so
just hiding out in Canada also wouldn't
work the most interesting thing for me
about a Don Jr indictment is how it's
going to set Trump off I can only
imagine Pat that Trump will lose his
mind if Don jr. is indicted and it's
going to be a new unraveling of tweets
and obstruction the likes of which up
until now we've likely only dreamed of
if this happens I think certainly things
are going to accelerate either Trump is
going to think about or maybe act on
firing Robert Muller or we at least know
that Muller is close to wrapping things
up and coming out with his final report
because if you're going to start in
dieting members of the president's
family I think you're pretty close to
coming out with your final assessment
something to look forward to I just hope
that they include this in the finale of
season 2 and don't wait until season 3
to get to this stuff because I don't
want to be kept hanging in that way over
the new year when the left and right are
talking about impeachment and
resignation you know that the walls are
starting to close in on the president
everything we've spoken about today
regarding the Michael Cohen memo Donald
Trump's failure to convince Mike Pence's
chief of staff
to fill in to take the job of chief of
staff John Kelly which we'll get to a
little bit later on in the show
everything that's going on right now
this has led even conservative columnist
to start thinking about Donald Trump's
exit strategy and there is a very
interesting clip from conservative
columnist Jennifer Rubin who was on
MSNBC she laid out what she thinks will
happen if in 2020 or 2024 a Democratic
president wins the presidential election
which is that Donald Trump will resign
ten minutes before Mike Pence does so
that pence can issue a pardon to Donald
Trump so I want to be clear I want to
restate this this is not the hypothesis
of some fringe bleeding-heart liberal
okay I'm talking about Jennifer Rubin
she's a conservative columnist she has
many opinions I disagree with but she
writes for The Washington Post she's an
attorney laborer an employment lawyer
for a long time and the point is this is
a serious person with serious
credentials who is not some kind of bomb
throwing lunatic left or right winger
and here is what she had to say about
this I also don't think that Trump can
pardon himself and if he tries that and
that's his only mechanism he risks being
prosecuted after he leaves office for
that very reason I would predict here on
MSNBC that when Trump leaves office he
will resign the presidency 10 minutes
before Mike Pence leaves office allowing
pence to pardon him if there is not a
Republican president to follow him the
one area where Jennifer Rubin may be
wrong or at least under estimating the
strength of that strategy is that there
are possible state crimes here those
don't go away with a presidential pardon
Allah Richard Nixon and this actually
gets to one of the core issues within
the resignation option I've been pretty
steadfast that if it comes down to it
Trump's not going to allow himself to be
impeached Donald Trump I have held will
resign before impeachment if it becomes
really clear that he risks being
impeached
and he will couch the resignation as to
crooked system evil Dems conspired
against me so I couldn't do anything
they put my friends in prison with these
bogus witch hunts and he will sort of
frame himself as a martyr and say that
he's resigning to fight back against the
system that's treating him so unfairly I
mean totally delusional framing but it
would at least allow some possibility of
keeping the support of the trumpet's
base so that part I think is sort of
realistic that Trump would resign rather
than be impeached but the next question
Pat is would Mike Pence pardon Donald
Trump the implication from Jennifer
Rubin is that yes but as much of a
disgusting ideological right-wing or as
Mike Pence is we don't actually know how
beholden he is to Donald Trump he has
been staying out of the limelight Pence
has been almost missing from the
presidency we don't know how compromised
Pence's in the entire thing I think
there are some realistic questions Pat
about whether Mike Pence would be party
to this pardon and resign idea that
Jennifer Rubin is presenting well you
alluded to Richard Nixon earlier a major
reason why Gerald Ford wasn't elected
for a term of his own was because he
pardoned Nixon and I think pence would
look at history and not want to find
himself in the same predicament also
just going along with Jennifer Rubens
theory I don't see why Mike Pence would
need to resign I mean there's nothing
maybe we'll learn more about what's
going on with the whole situation here
but there's nothing directly implicating
him in any of the crimes that we suspect
Trump and his associates of committing
yeah I found that interesting as well
that she mentioned that because that has
been a question for a while and one
could interpret Mike Pence's total lack
of public visibility as a way to
continue furthering the idea that he
just has nothing to do with any of this
stuff
it could also be that pence knows he's
as implicated as Trump but he's not
stupid enough to start tweeting and
attacking journalists and making public
statements so he's doing the sort of
more prudent
by staying out of it this is all totally
speculative but the mere fact that some
more reasonable conservative columnist
are starting to argue about how exactly
this is going to happen is pretty
telling we have a new bombshell report
in Newsweek which claims that
Republicans are more and more agitated
by Donald Trump's problems and by the
progress of the Russia investigation
which daily is tightening around Trump
and his family rather than loosening to
the point that Los Angeles Times
reporter Eli's Stowe khals said on MSNBC
yesterday that Republicans are privately
telling him that if Muller has more
wrongdoing by Trump than just these
felonies he directed Michael Cohen to
commit that if they obtain information
that suggests Trump approved of
wrongdoing or even had knowledge of
wrongdoing that they may dump Trump to
save the Republican Party check out what
Eli Stokes said yesterday to Nicole
Wallace on MSNBC but when all the facts
are laid out and people can see the
investigators work I think it's going to
be very problematic for this president
and there is some understanding I think
inside the White House of just how dark
it may be getting especially in terms of
conversations private conversations that
people they are having with Republicans
on the hill who are starting to be
concerned Republican lawmakers who are
have a huge role to play in this if it
goes forward are starting to tell me
privately some of them that you know if
there's obvious evidence the bottom is
gonna fall out they're not going to be
able to stand by this White House and
that's a looming problem for the
president so this is a reporter claiming
it there are right-wingers writing this
off as merely made-up but this is not a
pundit right Eli Stokes is a reporter
for the Los Angeles Times he has serious
sources in Washington DC he has no
reason to make this up the risks to him
professionally to just making this up
are huge and more importantly he's not
really saying anything that's hard to
believe privately on the condition of
anonymity Republicans are telling him
we're aware of how bad this is we are
aware that if it get
bad and it gets worse simply standing by
Trump no matter what comes out would be
bad for us obviously right who could
fault them for that they care about
self-preservation they don't really care
about Trump Trump's not even been a
Republican most of his life and he has
no particular loyalty to the Republican
Party beyond it being the team that he
chose to play on right now as president
Trump we would be expecting Republicans
to be saying this we stand behind Trump
up until the point at which it becomes
damaging for us and for the party and
then we're going to bail and
interestingly stoical said during the
same MSNBC appearance that the Giuliani
Trump plan right now is to keep
attacking the investigators we've said
this before Pat and will say it again I
don't remember who it was that tweeted
Sarah Huckabee Sanders maybe when you're
attacking FBI investigators you know
that you're in trouble if your strongest
tactic is to attack the people doing the
investigation you're not in a strong
position it sounds to me like attacking
investigators as a sign of weakness a
sign that they don't have anything and a
poor argument really what we're seeing
is the development of Trump from a sort
of political curiosity into a political
liability which was predicted pretty
early on in Trump's campaign that this
is what it would become and there may
even be some way in which Republicans as
they see the stock market become more
and more erratic as they see the jobs
numbers fall further and further behind
expectations as they see the world
laughing at us day in and day out there
are some Republicans who don't really
care about Trump who might be hoping
that whatever Moeller comes up with is
really serious and unequivocal and
definitive so that they can say listen
I'm a Republican and I like the
president but if he did something of
that bad then he just has to go
Republicans may be hoping that Robert
Muller provides them cover to dump Trump
now what would it mean to dump Trump
because that could take many forms one
would be related to what we talked about
earlier if the house does move to
impeach Donald Trump in the new Congress
publicans in the Senate could just get
on board right they could vote to remove
him although for some of them for many
of them maybe there would be political
consequences to doing that there are
slightly more subtle methods that
Republicans could employ for example
they could communicate the Donald Trump
that Republicans will not be supporting
him in his re-election campaign instead
they're going to be supporting a
challenger maybe Trump should consider
not running and allowing someone else to
run these are all extreme scenarios but
we're increasingly sort of operating in
a universe of extreme scenarios they
could negotiate if you drop out of
running for re-election
we won't impeach you or look to
prosecute you after you're out of office
many scenarios but the fact that any of
this is even being talked about means
we're already starting to approach what
could potentially be the end game phase
of this national nightmare or maybe
Trump just gets reelected and serves
eight full years and then leaves office
and never faces any consequences that's
also a possibility what do you think I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show and we'll
be back after this there is a report
very interesting article which we're
linking to which claims that Donald
Trump is glued to watching the stock
market and that he's starting to panic
about his role in causing what appears
to be a building recession which is hard
to believe for me only insofar as I've
seen no evidence that Trump can actually
self reflect about how he does things
poorly and about how he might be to
blame for things that happen in the
world I've not seen any evidence that
he's able to do that but the facts are
pretty obvious right the stock market is
in chaos last week we had an 800 point
drop one day followed by a drop of
around 400 points the following day
stocks now are down for the year about
three and a half to four percent not
including the fact that as I speak right
now the Dow is down another 500 points I
cry when I log into my retirement mutual
fund account it's extraordinarily
depressing and in addition to that you
have stocks down more than 10 percent
from their recent high
so down about four four and a half
percent for the year down about ten to
twelve percent from there Donald Trump
highs in addition to that we have a
disastrous jobs number we had a November
jobs report where new jobs fell short of
expectations by about 50,000 jobs that
momentum of job creation turned over to
trump by the Obama administration
continues to trail off a hundred and
fifty five thousand jobs created in
November about 50,000 jobs short of the
expectation now I have no interest in
being deceptive about the numbers job
creation is still better than job loss
right so that's good just remember that
the economy needs to create jobs just to
account for the growing population right
so the population grows so in order to
maintain an even unemployment rate you
need to be creating some jobs just to
account for new people who are in the
workforce because of population growth
okay
there's now a report from The Wall
Street Journal not a liberal newspaper
to be sure which claims that Donald
Trump is more and more panicked behind
the scenes he's watching the movement of
the stock market very closely he's
asking advisors if his tariffs might be
to blame for the economic turmoil and
sources are telling The Wall Street
Journal that overall Trump is still
mostly blaming the Federal Reserve's
interest rate decisions for the shaky
stock market but that the turmoil is
starting to get even to Donald Trump and
that's a sign that things really aren't
going well Pat because he doesn't
exactly have a personality type which
reflects about how he might be
responsible for anything bad that
happens even thinking about the fact
that he might be responsible for this
chaos tells us a lot about what's going
on and if this gets very very bad I'm
not sure what he's going to try to blame
it all on like I don't think that the
Federal Reserve raising interest rates
is going to be a point that sticks as to
why the economy in the stock market are
doing so poorly he's going to have to
come up with something better than that
and I think it's probably accurate to
say that in instead of
Trump is worried that he's causing the
the turmoil it might be more accurate to
say Trump is worried that other people
will blame him for causing the turmoil
right so along those lines you could
argue that this leak about Trump quote
panicking about stocks and jobs is not
Trump being worried that he's damaging
the economy but Trump being worried that
others will blame him of that and that
he doesn't actually believe it because
again there's no evidence that I've seen
that Donald Trump is capable of the kind
of introspection and self-reflection
that this leak suggests he has even
though rational people of course
realized that Donald Trump has kind of
cornered himself by taking credit for
things in the economy during his first
year that really didn't have anything to
do with him the perception of Trump as
an economic genius is now in question
among people who actually were tricked
into believing that in the first place
I'm not one of those people Donald Trump
obviously still wants to see himself as
the economic genius but he's starting to
realize that others are going to start
questioning what what exactly is Trump
doing that's making jobs reports get
worse and worse
what exactly is Trump doing that's
putting the stock market into a freefall
and in real terms for any president it's
a bad idea to brag about the stock
market particularly when it's the stock
market of the Obama economy that Donald
Trump inherited Trump owns the next two
years of this term and we'll see what
direction that takes and a really
important note and I want to make sure
that I'm not ignoring this when we talk
about stocks and job numbers many of the
indicators that really relate to how the
average person is doing are not
represented from stocks and jobs wages
accessibility of health care
affordability of education inflation
meaning how much things cost inequality
none of that stuff is noted in these
numbers and those are extraordinarily
important indicators so yes these
numbers stocks and jobs matter they seem
to have Trump rattled they are a part of
understanding how the economy is doing
but there is much more much more that we
need to look at to really do a holistic
assessment of how the economy is doing
send me your thoughts about this
particular question do you believe Trump
is actually capable at a sort of fitness
level a temperamental level of
considering whether his actions are
resulting in bad things or is this just
a leak to try to make Trump look more
introspective than he is the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman I look forward to
hearing from you okay wait wait wait
wait if you're watching on YouTube and
you've shown up to troll before hitting
dislike and leaving a negative nasty
comment consider watching the video
first okay I was really surprised over
the weekend people started sending me
links to a tweet that Jordan Peterson
sent out saying David you've got to talk
about this dumb thing that Jordan
Peterson said and I presumed it would be
some kind of esoteric nuanced statement
which could be interpreted 10 different
ways or I'd critique it and his
followers would say no David you're
misunderstanding what he said or that's
not what he meant or you just don't have
the capacity to know what he's really
talking about but then I saw the tweet
and I started to wonder whether
something was wrong because this is
bizarre even for Jordan Peterson and I'm
gonna explain this entire thing to you
and if you haven't heard of Jordan
Peterson he's a psychologist and sort of
self-help dude whose teachings have
really resonated with many young men
around the world he came to prominence
for his opposition to a bill in Canada
which he said would threaten to jail
people for using the wrong gender
pronouns which of course was never true
and Peterson suggested that misgendering
people are using the wrong pronouns
could be considered hate speech which
could conceivably get you jail time but
of course misgendering people has never
been considered hate speech by Canadian
courts Canadian courts have a really
high threshold for what counts as hate
speech but the entire thing worked
really well for Peterson to build him a
big following so he's doing very well
so anyway over the weekend Jordan
Peterson tweeted positive comments about
a guy named Bourne Lomborg
our discussion today you don't have to
know anything about Lomborg because what
matters is what peterson said about him
which was via twitter that quote he's
casually called a climate change denier
for example which is an appallingly
treacherous term of criticism used to
denigrate someone personally by
associating them with holocaust deniers
the ethics of anyone who employs it
should be instantly questioned so layer
one is that in no way does calling
someone a climate change denier imply or
effin reference that they're in any way
like holocaust deniers i mean just it in
no way whatsoever
contrary to Peterson's own views he
seems to have been triggered by
innocuous language climate denier and
he's trying to police language such that
those whose views on climate changed are
not based on science are not called
deniers anymore and then he's also
virtue signaling by calling into
question the ethics of anyone who uses
the term climate change denier I look
around I looked hard and there's no
evidence whatsoever anywhere that the
term climate denier is deliberately or
even by sheer consequence referencing or
implying anything like Holocaust denial
peterson is arguing that calling people
deniers of things is effectively an ad
hominem looking to associate them with
people who deny the Holocaust I mean
it's patently patently ludicrous and
absurd climate change the latest
neo-marxist post modernist plot which is
absolutely destroying the lives of young
men everywhere by questioning the
archetypes of dominance hierarchies are
dominant hierarchies I guess I need to
reset I went into Jordan Peterson
talking point coma there so that's layer
one okay I mean truly just a dumb thing
to say but here's where it gets even
better in 2016 Peterson tweeted the that
a University of Toronto professor
is a biological sex denier saying quote
utoronto prof a biological sex denier on
Canadian public television with me
Jordan Peterson absolutely obliterates
Jordan Peterson right he is now claiming
that the phraseology of X denier insert
here denier is an ad hominem meant to
link people to Holocaust denial and he
did the exact same thing when he called
the University of Toronto professor a
biological sex denier how do people
listen to this guy I mean truly picking
and choosing when to be offended going
against his own stated principles but
more importantly saying really silly
things like calling someone a climate
change denier when that's what they're
doing they're denying the overwhelming
established science on climate change is
like likening someone to a Holocaust
denier and actually Pat many people in
our audience may not know but aside from
his self-help ideas Peterson has become
a pretty stalwart climate science denier
huh that's pretty interesting you know
when you listen to the jordan peterson
speak he often talks very slowly he
takes these long pauses and you get the
impression that he really wants to
formulate his ideas and make sure that
he's communicating clearly and yet he
seems to routinely have gas like these
like when he talks about enforced
monogamy or many many different examples
climate change denial all this stuff you
wouldn't suspect that for someone who
chooses his words so carefully and yet
peterson repeatedly makes gas like these
yes and here is another one and if
anyone wants to defend this by all means
i'm ready to hear from you and it is not
just because he is on on the right that
i am talking about him i also talk about
people on the Left who say things that
don't make sense and that's exactly what
i'm going to do next talking about
alexandria kasi
Cortese so I think everybody's going to
end up upset with me because of this
segment we have big news to talk about
today we we sort of are moving from to
make this an analogy to sort of a chess
game we're moving from the mid game to
the endgame and in the fiasco that is
the Donald Trump presidency JA Donald
Trump is now privately expressing
concern that he's going to get impeached
now to be clear I already know that if
you're at rumpus you're going to call
this entire story fake news so don't
even bother just skip it don't even
bother writing to me about it I know
that you're not going to believe
anything about this report now for
everybody else let's actually talk about
what's going on there's a new report
with multiple sources which tells us
that Donald Trump privately is
expressing concern about being impeached
when Democrats take over the house in
January of 2019 when it comes to why
Donald Trump thinks he'd be impeached it
is only related to the campaign finance
violations connected to Michael Cohen's
felonies and guilty pleas Trump does not
think that he will be impeached for
so-called Russian collusion or for
obstruction of justice or any of that
stuff he believes it will be an
impeachment solely because of the
payoffs to former mistresses felonies
which Michael Cohen participated in
committed under the specific direction
of Donald Trump now Trump likewise seems
to understand that the house merely
brings the impeachment forward
ultimately it would be up to the Senate
to vote on whether to remove Donald
Trump from office Republicans of course
hold the Senate they're going to
continue holding the Senate in 2019
Donald Trump does not think that
Republicans would vote for his removal
except that there's another story from
Capitol Hill today which I'll talk about
next which might make us question that
assumption assumption but I agree with
Trump in a sense which is that if the
only incident at issue is that of the
campaign finance related felonies that
Michael Michael Cohen pleaded guilty to
which we know that he did at Donald
Trump's direction I agree I don't think
the Senate a republican-controlled
Senate is going to vote to impeach
Donald Trump on that basis the more
pressing question is do we really
believe that by the time it's all set in
the undone by the time Robert Muller is
finished here that those felonies
committed by Michael Cohen at Donald
Trump's direction are going to be the
only thing that we're going to have on
Trump I don't think that that's likely
it doesn't seem that Donald Trump
actually knows the full scope of what
Muller has on him right now the campaign
finance felonies will be nothing if we
end up with evidence of Trump trading
promises of sanctions relief to a
foreign power in exchange for help
defeating Hillary Clinton and we haven't
even gotten to all of the obstruction so
if Trump's position right now is based
on the idea that only the campaign
finance felonies will be at issue I tend
to agree with him he's not going to get
impeached over that the question is what
else will we know by the time it's all
said and done the obstruction Fiasco as
an example is well documented in the
public domain
never mind what investigators have which
we just don't know yet at this point I
don't know what Trump's smocking to take
a vocabulary word out of his recent
tweets I don't know what from smocking
if he thinks mistress payoffs are
ultimately going to be the only issue
here most of the Democrats I've seen
interviewed so far Pat understand this
is not the time to talk about
impeachment a couple of Democrats have
talked about it I think it's a strategic
mistake I believe at this point what
Democrats should be saying about what
are you going to do once you take over
in January focus on what they want to do
for the American people when they take
over talk about what they want to
investigate the investigative power of
the house is powerful but let the facts
lead them to impeachment if ultimately
they will rather than talking now about
any plan to impeach Trump yeah I
certainly think that most Democrats
recognized that it would be a bad idea
to impeach him knowing that they
probably couldn't get him out of office
that they couldn't get the 67 votes
needed in the Senate and all
so if it was over something like
campaign finance violations related to a
mistress payoff like a very similar
thing happened with Bill Clinton in 98
it was impeached for lying about a
sexual affair this is kind of similar
right it's the same kind of scope and
scale and I don't think they're gonna
want to repeat that mistake no I think
you're gonna they're going to need more
and I the one area where I disagree is
if they have more on Trump by March 2019
June 2019 even if it's not something
that would get Republicans in the Senate
to act to remove Trump I actually would
be okay with filing impeachment with
moving forward with impeachment in the
house if it's the right thing to do I
just think that it's going to be a tough
one to move forward on if all we have is
these Cohen felonies which Trump
directed but I am confident that there's
going to be more I would be shocked if
there isn't more by the time it's all
said and done but the one thing I'm not
mentioning here yet is what if
Republicans do decide that they're sick
of Donald Trump and that's what I want
to talk about next I know I'm going to
get hate for this segment but it has to
be done if I don't hold progressives to
the same standards as conservatives what
am i doing right I agree with Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez on many issues but if that
excuses her from critical analysis of
what she's doing and what she's saying I
am doing a disservice to everyone in the
audience and I lose credibility so I'm
not picking on her here I know that
she's new but no one is forcing her to
say the things she's been saying on
Twitter and during interviews she's a
congresswoman elect and she is now
subject to scrutiny I care so much about
the progressive movement that I don't
want anyone including her going out and
saying things that don't make any sense
now she recently tweeted that there's a
double standard that when Paul Ryan was
elected to Congress at age 28 everybody
called the mad genius but people are
calling her a fraud for being 29 and
having been elected to Congress I never
called Paul Ryan a genius I'm
calling her a fraud I'm merely analyzing
her statements the same way I would
anyone with the context that I agree
with a lot of reviews so please don't
lump this in with the irrational anti
AOC stuff that has infected the right
let's get into it
first problem AOC starts tweeting about
Medicare for all great full disclosure I
support Medicare for all there's a
number of very serious studies about how
it is that medicare for all would save
us money in the net and if you ask right
now in the Democratic Party who are some
of the most prominent Medicare for all
voices voices in favor of Medicare for
all alexandria Castillo Cortez is
probably one of them no doubt that's
great I agree with the policy but then
she goes on Twitter and says quote 21
trillion dollars of Pentagon financial
transactions could not be traced
documented or explained 21 trillion
dollars in Pentagon accounting errors
Medicare for all costs 32 trillion
dollars that means 66 percent of
Medicare for all could have been funded
already by the Pentagon and that's
before our premiums this is really dumb
okay this is this is silly her argument
is we don't even really need to worry
about what Medicare for all will cost
because two-thirds of the cost could be
funded from the missing money and
accounting errors of the Pentagon now
it's true that there's a ton of money in
so-called missing money but it's not
money that's missing in the sense that
if you find it then you can use it
there's a major problem here with the
reasoning there are transactions that
are inadequately
documented by the Pentagon there is no
evidence that the money is sitting
around somewhere and could be used to
pay for part of Medicare for all this is
just the wrong argument in favor of
Medicare for all this is based on just
an incredibly simplistic
misunderstanding by the congresswoman
elect about what it means that the
Pentagon has lost track of money she's
sort of furthering the idea that the 21
trillion might be just somewhere
and as soon as we find it we can pay for
2/3 of medicare-for-all that's just not
the case we're talking about money that
is improperly accounted for or tracked
or documented these are accounting
issues they're not there's a pile of
money sitting around it's a really
simple mistake which she just can't be
making okay we have good ways to talk
about paying for Medicare for all this
is a way to self-sabotage Medicare for
all activism someone's just got to
explain it to her now somebody did
apparently later explain it to her and
she followed up Daffy after being
criticized by saying well I'm not
literally saying use the missing
Pentagon money I'm just making a
comparison about how the the numbers
being thrown around for Medicare for all
aren't that much bigger than these
so-called accounting errors but it was
too late the initial tweet got all the
attention and she was flat-out wrong
nonpartisan fact checkers have no choice
but to say this is wrong and this is you
know pants on fire for Pinocchio's
whatever scale they use and that's bad
for the movement that I support next she
gets into it with Donald Trump jr. on
Twitter now again full disclaimer I like
Alexandria Castillo Cortez I agree with
lots of her politics I find Donald Trump
jr. to be a disgusting human being I
think he's committed crimes for which he
will be indicted
but Alexandria Castillo courts has
messed up again appearing to threaten to
use her political power to get back at
Don junior for making fun of her on the
Internet
Donald Trump jr. posted a disgusting
meme about Alexandria Castillo Cortes
which had a picture of her and said why
are you so afraid of a socialist economy
followed by a picture of Donald Trump
saying because Americans want to walk
their dogs not eat them now of course
both communist and non-communist
countries around the world sometimes
have the tradition of seeing dogs is
just another type of animal whose meat
we might eat it's not really a big
political insight right so far
Alexandria Castillo Cortez has the upper
hand she's been targeted in a disgusting
and stupid way by Don jr. but then she
tweets
quote I have noticed that junior here
has a habit of posting nonsense about me
whenever the Moller investigation heats
up please keep it coming junior it's
definitely a very very large brain idea
to troll a member of a body that will
have subpoena power in a month have fun
big mistake I get it
Don juniors disgusting I can't stand the
guy he's posting horrible things I
support the house using its subpoena
power for investigations but this is an
unforced error we don't subpoena people
for trolling online we subpoena them
because we determine that they should be
subpoenaed for participation and
potential crimes knowledge about crimes
or for other reasons the mere
implication Pat that his trolling is
something that might get him subpoenaed
is an unforced error completely
misguided and she really shouldn't be
doing this yeah I think she absolutely
should be doing better here and maybe
there's a case we made that we should
have some sort of farm League right
before progressives get into the upper
ranks of Congress they should first you
have some sort of training maybe run for
lower-level offices so they can kind of
build up that repertoire and all that
experience there's certainly a trade-off
here because when you have younger
less-experienced folks in office their
fiery they're creative they can rally
people behind them but they're also more
prone to making mistakes and that's
what's been going on here yeah and of
course there would be no way to enforce
that farm League but I understand what
you're saying that when you are sort of
shoved into the limelight in such a
prominent and rapid way that this type
of stuff can happen and right-wingers
now we're saying she may have even
broken the law by doing this I don't
think she did but this is a completely
unforced and avoidable error and Friday
I'm going to deal with what she should
be doing but to sort of give you an
overview its media training and getting
more informed about basic economics and
history and sort of how government works
I mean there's no secret here she's
going to learn this stuff and I say this
all with peace and love lots of
attention is being paid to her I don't
want her
the movement I support because she's
making this miss these mistakes which
make her a target in a way that is not
necessary and his counterproductive if
you disagree and I know many of you will
let me know but my criticism here is not
an attack on her it's because I want her
to be a steward of the movement in which
we share so many ideals . . that's my
objective follow me on instagram at
david pakman the show is also on
instagram a david pakman show quick
break and then part two of my interview
with Zoltan Istvan is coming up next we
could have had
JD Schulten in Iowa's fourth
congressional district but instead
incumbent lunatic outrageous ideological
disgusting neo-nazi white nationalist
associated Republican Steve King was
able to retain his seat in an arrow win
that got us to yesterday when the house
had a hearing where they questioned
Google CEO sundar Pichai the idea I
guess was to explore bias and search
result sort of but the questions were
mostly uninformed and based in vague
conspiracy theories about Google
manipulating search results and a total
lack of practical technology knowledge
by the members of the committee and at
one point during these hearings Steve
King who again is a totally clueless guy
tied to white nationalists but one of
the worst Republicans in the House of
Representatives he angrily demanded
answers from Google's CEO about how an
iphone works which of course is not made
by Google it's made by Apple which is
actually sort of a competitor to Google
at least on some platforms there is so
much going on in the clip I'm about to
play for you that I want to prepare you
for it so number one you'll notice that
when Steve King asks this question to
sundar pichai he actually hesitates for
a second sundar does you can see him
weighing the options and debating in his
own mind do I give some kind of
diplomatic answer about how iPhones work
or do I treat this guy like The [ __ ]
that he is in explain
that Google just simply doesn't make the
iPhone watch for that crucial moment
where you can see him running through
the possibilities in his head you're
also going to notice that in the
background of the video there's someone
dressed like the monopoly guy like from
the board game Monopoly that's Ian
Madrigal who has shown up before at
hearings dressed as uncle Pennybags from
Monopoly to call attention to the
lobbying money that floats around
Congress so all of that and more is
happening in this clip let's take a look
I have a seven-year-old granddaughter
who picked up her phone before the
election and she's playing a little game
kind of game a kid would play and up on
there pops a picture of her grandfather
and I'm not gonna say into their record
what the kind of language was used
around that picture of her grandfather
but I'd ask you how does that show up on
a seven-year-olds iPhone who's playing a
kids game congressmen iPhone is made by
a different company and so you know I
mean it might have been an Android it's
just it was a hand-me-down or some guy
named you know I guess I'm happy to
follow up and understand the specifics
it there may be an application which was
being used which had a notification but
I'm happy to understand it better and
clarify it for you
okay thank you for your testimony and
yield back the balance of my time
this is just just amazing and the
defenders are saying oh listen the
question could have applied to Android
or iPhone it's such a stupid question I
mean quite frankly it's such a stupid
question and so that's like the headline
goofy outrageous clip but there's
actually plenty of Democrats and
Republicans exposing how clueless they
are about how the internet works during
this hearing here's another one this is
congressman Lamar Smith a Republican
from Texas he asks Google's CEO to
confirm that Google has never punished
anybody for manipulating search results
and Google's CEO says no because no
individual person can do that take a
look number two also to my knowledge
you've never sanctioned any employee for
any type of for manipulating the
research results whatsoever is that the
case the
the gentleman has expired but mr. pitch
I will be allowed to answer the question
and very quickly it's not possible for
an individual employee or groups of
employee to manipulate our search
results you know we have a robust
framework including many steps in the
process well and as my time is up let me
just say I disagree I think humans can
manipulate the process is a human
process at his face Thank You mr.
chairman you back chair ignite this is
just the best Lamar Smith disagrees he
knows nothing about anything but he
disagrees his feelings override the
facts he feels like individual employees
can mess with search results and he
wants them punished even though that's
not how it works now of course I know in
some broad sense it's true right I mean
humans made Google so humans control how
the algorithm works but the idea that
you'd punish individuals for
manipulating search results is a bit
silly and it just shows how clueless
Lamar Smith is there are other clips if
you want to see more Steve King is a
[ __ ] we know that his constituents had
a chance to vote him out they opted to
reelect him okay the bigger picture from
these hearings is that it exposes that
we have members of Congress who don't
know a thing about technology in charge
of figuring this stuff out this is why
instead of mostly older lawyers and CEOs
from industry we need younger people we
need people from more diverse
backgrounds scientists people from more
diverse professions case in point we
found out after Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham had been on some tech
committee maybe it was cybersecurity
don't remember exactly he had been on
this committee for a while it was
revealed that he had never sent an email
in his life Lindsey Graham 63 years old
email has been around in some forms
since he was 17 years old
admittedly it wasn't ubiquitous back
then but it's been around and commonly
used since Lindsey Graham was in his
mid-30s Pat why does he have to be on a
cybersecurity or tech committee if he's
never even sent an email like is this
really the best that we can do this is
the best that we have like he said most
of these people are lawyers and they've
been politicians for decades so they
don't understand tech and it's not this
they can't ask tough questions I think
they can and they can press these CEOs
and make sure that they get to the
bottom of things but they should do less
grandstanding and more listening at the
end of the day yeah I mean just the the
questions expose how little they
understand about how things work and I'm
reminded of that law someone at one
point in New York State got off on child
porn charges because of how the Raw law
was written just viewing child porn is
is not possessing it because you didn't
like right click save as to your
computer and this allowed people at
least one person potentially more to get
out of child porn charges then they went
in and changed the law and it's this
kind of reactive situation we need on
issues of Technology and cybersecurity
we need our elected officials to be
proactive you can't be proactive unless
you have some understanding of what the
hell is going on however impressive it
might be what Barron Trump is doing with
computers we actually need our elected
officials not the children of presidents
to be knowledgeable informed and working
for us and proactively rather than
seemingly indifferent to how the real
world actually operates when it comes to
these technologies I mean just just
embarrassing in every way and hopefully
I mean the upside is that Steve Kings
cartoonish demand of sundar Pichai to
explain how an iPhone works even though
Apple makes iPhone not Google if it
serves the purpose of bringing this
hearing out into the open so more people
realize the degree of cluelessness that
our elected officials have on these
issues I would consider that a benefit a
net gain of Steve King saying really
dumb things